Ever right now.
He's 22 he's making money.
He's a fucking savage.
Come on.
He started specials.
Where he belongs right here.
He saw it.
Look,
I mean,
he's just,
he does everything so well.
Everything from his de France two is striking and Rehab did.
He looks like a world champion boxer when he's got his hands up.
It doesn't mean he can't get caught.
Doesn't mean he can't get finished.
He can.
He'll get a little reckless.
This motherfucker got to keep your hands getting.
He's going to be so good.
He hit so fucking hard through his body shots.
His left took his day.
One of the best love.
Ooh.
When would the Duchy.
Oh Shit elbow.
Oh Gosh.
A cart with a rabbit a little bit.
Definitely got hit in her.
Correct.
This is a real fight.
You Know Morales hand Corrales are tough.
Pico also has a crazy six pack to
tell you what I tell you here under four bro.
Oh,
the left hooks coming.
There's one that's coming inside.
He's a little,
he's a little concussed.
Corrals says little concussed paralysis.
Morales.
Okay.
Paralysis.
Cream and corrals is not tow needed.
The body shots too bad smart page.
Oh Shit.
Oh No.
Brendan just fell out of his fucking chair.
Oh my God.
Oh No.
That's what happens.
That's what happens in fighting.
That's what happens in Friday.
Holy Shit speech.
I don't like seeing a young man get hit like that.
That was crazy.
A poor or Brennan punched.
Watch this.
Watch this again.
Why?
Why is he so reckless?
The savage,
but
Luke,
he's 22 he'll learn,
but watch this,
John Jones and do this.
So he just,
he just wades in and you could tell the corrals had recovered.
Look at this body shot.
Body shot hurts him there.
Hello.
No snaps back out.
Cold out cold.
Two big bumps.
Look at this one more time.
Boom.
That's all she wrote,
Dude.
Everything goes on.
The Drake of
the way down.
His head is not.
That's not going to see again,
look at this.
Boom,
perfect shot.
The lights go out in Georgia,
one too on the way down and then a third one when he's already out cold.
Holy Shit.
That's some killer instinct right there.
That could stop you.
You know you're talking about this progression that stop you.
Well,
yeah,
the first,
he doesn't know what happened.
He's,
he's,
he's trying to figure out what happened now.
I mean,
he was comprised,
he's going,
fuck this MMA style.
You understand my deathbed confessional now.
Yes,
astral traveling,
but your,
your deathbed confessional.
You're correct.
He could've taken him down.
Who's going to stop Aaron Peko from take.
Could it be dumb?
Can beat them.
Here's the thing,
not too,
but here's the thing.
You can do all things.
You can do all things,
but if you're standing in front of a guy all the time,
if you get that guy hurt,
the way he got that heart,
that guy hurt.
If your objective,
okay,
it's easy to be Monday,
Monday morning quarterback,
right?
But objective looking at right now,
I would say take him down.
He's hurt.
Take him down,
smash them up and then you take no dammit.
Fuck no chances.
It's all variables.
It's all about mitigating variables.
You close all the variables down.
When you take God down a mountain and start dropping elbows on his head,
you close all the variables.
If you can maintain the mount position and keep punching and you already know
he's fucked up,
God,
it's all it's about of whether he's going to tap the strikes or are you going to
get a choke?
I don't like.